PROFESSOR: Many of you
have heard of MOOCs.
They're very famous,
Massively Open Online Courses.
MOOCs are very open and large
classes, often with thousands
or tens of thousands
of participants.
And MOOCs are essentially
a big movement
to really democratize education.
SPOCs are a little different.
So 16.842 was run as a SPOC,
which stands for Small Private
Online Course.
So like a MOOC, a SPOC
is also offered online.
You can take it in person
in a classroom at one
of the hosting
universities or you
can take it entirely online.
It's really up to you.
It's small because we have
a few dozen students instead
of thousands, and it's
private because in order
to take the class
it's by invitation.
In this particular instance,
we had two universities that
co-sponsored this class.
One is MIT and the
other one is called
EPFL, Ecole Polytechnique
Federale de Lausanne
in Switzerland, which is also
quite active in the world
of online education.
The way fundamentally
that a SPOC works,
is that you have the
course management
system at each of the hosting
universities and institutions.
And you essentially post the
same materials, the lectures,
the readings, the
exercises, you post them
in parallel at each of
the hosting universities.
The lecturers
themselves, however,
are run online using an
open collaboration platform,
like WebEx for example.
You can do it with
Google Hangouts.
There's a lot of
different platforms.
And this is important
because it is
important to have live
connections between the faculty
and the students,
but also the students
amongst themselves can discuss.
The trickiest part of
running a SPOC, of course,
is the time zones and
the time differences.
In this case, the
two universities
were six time zones apart.
And so it was offered in the
morning here at MIT and then
the afternoon in Europe.
If you're running this
as a global class,
it will be more
challenging to find a time
slot that works for everybody.
The feedback from the students
has been very positive,
because you can think of a
SPOC in this particular class
as a blended form of education.
Part of the class is live.
The lectures are given live,
and every lecture is recorded.
So even if you miss a
lecture as a student,
you can watch it later.
And so there's a record of it.
The assignments
are asynchronous,
and there are some assignments
that are individual.
And there are team
assignments as well.
And so it's a blended
form of education,
which is an important
trend in education where
we take the best of
the online experience,
and we try to combine
it with the best
of the in-person experience.
Teaching a SPOC is fun and
challenging at the same time.
It's fun because you get
to converse and interact
with students, not just in
a physical classroom at one
university but across
multiple institutions.
And that enhances the class,
because students will speak up
with experiences from
different cultural backgrounds.
But it's also
challenging, because you
have to keep track of what's
happening at multiple places.
And you have a mix of students
from different backgrounds
and different institutional
constraints as well.
And so it's both
challenging and fun,
but it's a very
focused experience.
And the feedback from the
students has been great.